euh d'après une étude du chirurgien
pâtissier plasticien Julian Da Silva le
nouveau plus bel homme du monde serait
l'acteur Roger janpage qui joue le rôle
de Simon Basset dans la série Les
Chroniques de Bridgestone pour ceux qui
ne le connaissent pas regardez on a une
petite compile de rejet il y a pas de
rejet
er
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour vous c'est qui l'homme le plus beau
du monde alors j'ai choisi deux hommes
de mon âge enfin un peu plus que moi
j'ai pris chez les blonds Brad Pitt et
chez les poivres et sel George Clooney
non mais attends
quand même magnifique
je trouve de ouf tout le monde me le dit
la dernière fois j'étais dans la rue
j'aime bien le gars que au bout de la
table j'ai dit qu'il m'a dit tu ne cesse
de Johnny Hallyday
parce que en fait vous savez moi je me
mets jamais en avant vous le savez
c'est principal si j'en ai une c'est
l'humilité et si vous reprenez le gars
dont on dit que c'est le plus beau mec
du monde 34 ans etc il fait un peu
gravure de mode sans charme vous mettez
ma photo à côté ce que j'ai pas mes
chances non mais dit franchement
pourquoi vous me regardez comme ça ne
faites pas ça ça va pas
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
vous savez que ce monsieur là il est
quand même pressenti pour être James
Bond qui le celui qui a été choisi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien tiens
Raymond c'est pour toi moi je suis pas
très je n'arrive pas à trouver un homme
beau mais je trouve que Beckham BK
mais là il est pas bon non plus
David Beckham tu prenais que des mecs
qui sont vraiment qui vous ressemblent
de ouf c'est incroyable et du coup vous
prenez qui vous bah moi
c'est le même
c'est le même une oreille et moi moi
j'ai une anecdote avec mon fils il y
avait David Beckham on est allé à la
Coupe du monde à Doha et il y avait il y
a David Beckham qui arrive qui était
dans le même loge que nous et donc il y
a mon fils tiens tu vas prendre une
photo avec quelqu'un comme ça non
[Rires]
Géraldine toi moi alors moi les Daniel
j'aime beaucoup alors pourquoi mon
Daniel soit Daniel Craig
Daniel Craig également
chez les hommes là avec le regard bleu
intense
toutes les cas ce soir
moi j'ai pris Cyril Féraud de slam
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il aurait mangé Cyril fémont
Daniel mort ou vivante
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai cette photo à côté de mon lit et je
m'endors à regarder parce que ça va
c'est pareil
excuse-moi c'est autre chose
merci exactement
[Rires]
parce que le savoir est une arme et
j'aime les hommes mais mentalement
non ma question on l'adore franchement
vous êtes que des conneries moi j'en ai
marre sans Hugo
qui ressemble à Johnny Hallyday
[Applaudissements]